hello good morning thank you very much
for coming here to my talk
the I am Jose miss Gomez minions from
tecnológico de Monterrey in Mexico I am
a calculus teacher and for this project
I did collaborate with Professor Luis
Vargas Mendoza he is a mechanical
engineering professor and we remain
Dario Santa Acosta he's a mathematics
professor and the title is as you can
see cloud apps from wild learning of
calculus and engineering design so ok
here well as you know there are many
commercial apps for mobile learning
however when the structure has a very
specific need then the flexibility and
power of the world from language and is
cloud approach abilities can be used to
create specific solutions that was
actually the case for a curse on machine
elements in mechanical design at our
university during design requires many
iterations of tedious calculations and
students must have time to analyze the
result of each one and take decisions to
perform the next iteration the that loop
in mechanical engineering design can be
represented with this simplified model
ok where the students have some or the
one the designer has some general
information he is going to feed a
specific information into the sign
operation will have a result and then
the it has to evaluate the result to see
if it already has the correct element
the correct gear or the correct shaft or
whatever if not it has to go back now in
the case of the students mechanical
engineering they were taking a lot of
time in the part of the design operation
right and the structure wanted them to
have more time to spend in the
evaluation time to see actually well we
did all these calculations now do we
have fear that it's not the size or
something like that or microscopic
whatever and and if it is the case then
go back and then go back so they
working before with Excel that were
working with books tables and all of
that that was too clumsy okay so the
idea was to have an app and it has to be
a very specifically designed app so that
they can work very fast or faster the
design operation and spend more time in
the evaluation part that was the idea
now we started exploring where the web
capabilities of the form function and we
started to run in some problems and we
had to create some hacks and some my
ideas to do work on this for example
here we have a very a very simple code
for a form function and maybe you can
see that in the output it's supposed to
be with colors I have the code here the
output is supposed to have some colors
in the background now if I actually run
this app over here then it runs very
good but we don't have the background
okay that's not yet implemented or it
was not yet implemented for the version
11 point 2 for the work cloud that we
were using this year so now we figure
out one way to solve this problem the
problem was to actually use the third
argument of the form function to specify
that the output is a gif file so if I
now run this version that has give here
as a third argument of the form function
that's pretty much the same and I write
here there we go
and of course this could be you can make
it larger to see it now and the same
goes for actually the mathematical
notation the best way we found to get it
right was actually to use the final
output as a gif image maybe it's not the
ideal case but there was one of the many
hacks when it tricks we had to use to
solve the problems that we were having
right are we took out somehow out some
of them now now actually a better
technique to work with all of the things
that we wanted to do
would be asked for asked function and
all of the asked commands really would
ask function but we avoided it because
it was mark as experimental in the
documentation at a time and I think it
still is so that's why we went to use
the form function and in the case of
these calculations there are a lot of
calculations there that you had to do we
choose to use a multi-page from function
okay now when using a multi-page from
function now we run into another problem
it seems so I believe that the way works
that each page in a multi-page function
it's already there and you and your
Colonel I think sai-san you can know and
therefore the sometimes there is
information that is lost when going from
one page to the other right so not the
data that the user inputs that's okay
because data that the user inputs it's
actually it's going to be fed correctly
into the next page which is a function
but you have some variables that are
calculated from that sometimes and
that's the weird thing not always
sometimes the values of those variables
are lost so since the calculations here
were rather simple the thing that we did
in order to solve this was that we use a
with with the calculation sorry I I
minimize this I'm sorry yeah so you can
see that here we have a with a structure
with many things fine and among them we
have things like this this has some some
group of calculations that had to be
done
we from some of the input of the user as
you can see there are very simple
calculations they are called here
calculus in a matica and if we go down
down down to the code it's a lot of
thing in the width before actually going
to the from function here finally have
the form function this is the first page
of the form function you will see
working in a moment now this is the
second page this is the third page and
so on and then
in some moment I need to do the
calculations and here you have remember
calculus in America was there so here
the calculations are done from the input
of the previous pages right another
thing is that since as I told you that
information can be lost for the next
page in the e if I need it in the next
page I do it again I mean this was kind
of a maybe it's an ugly hack but it
works okay because otherwise the
information is lost from one page to the
other right and so that's what we do and
again and again and again and as you can
see there are many pages here actually
all of these I am just going to show you
an example very fast of this app running
here let me show you here and I will see
if I can copy/paste this because I want
to yeah that's like what I want okay
so I hope that the transmission is not
so bad
we have this is the app for upgrading
gears or for learning to calculate years
I am you is going to input some values
here just to give you some some feeling
of how does it work
fine and that's the first page only and
then you go and it shows you some
results it asks you you would why you
will like this resource to be in the
final screen you can say no and then
some more calculations some of them
depend on the previous input of the user
some of them don't and and the student
the user is shown at every step
intermediate results so maybe he decides
ready to go back this is for example the
useful life for the for the gear maybe
you can ask for 20,000 hours cetera and
he goes on and on and on
and on any showing you intermediate
information you see if we can have the
translation here yeah so and goes oh no
no no no no a very long calculation but
now the students can do it very fast
reach the end and see if they have a
gear that makes sense right because
maybe they have a cure that fulfils all
the conditions but it's a size or
something like this it will not work
right and that's exactly what the
instructor wanted then they want he
wanted them to spend time in that part
in the valuation part so he well here we
had the students and I'd like to
emphasize that they can use any device
to to see and to work with the app in a
phone or an iPad or a computer whatever
we also created a well drive design up
same idea and that band chance is that
we can tailor that we can specifically
design for the need so far the the
instructure
so and here I assure you a screenshot
here below of the of the up you can see
that in this case we actually make the
graph of the representing the belt and
the shaft yeah and well the say was very
nice because instructure was very
surprised that not only did the series
actually spend more time in the
evaluation part well they had
experienced that they were able to
actually generate several different
successful designs not only one but
several that never happened to him
before yeah and they came with several
options that will solve the problem and
also feed that from the students was in
general positive here are some graphs
well showing that most of the feedback
is positive and actually the interesting
thing is that students were kind of the
ambitious or demanding from the app now
they wanted to have an animation
animated okay say come home please but
they wanted more more more from from the
from the from the app okay
and now after that experience with this
mechanical engineering
the sign now we are starting to explore
adaptive learning adaptive learning
sorry and here I have a scheme at there
are many possibilities for making a
schema for that deep learning here we
have a scheme where maybe the student
enters here and one could be a first
question if the student get is right
goes to n to the second level or second
set of questions maybe the first one is
about a graphical function the next one
about the domain of a function the next
one is about the translation of
functions whatever different topics
right and he if he gets everything right
poom poom-poom he pinches but if he
somewhere there starts to struggle and
has some question wrong then the app
will make a second question of the same
topic maybe an easier one right kind of
what happens with duolingo when you are
while you're learning languages and it
will adapt the kind of questions and
it's an integer this idea right and here
is it is just a very simple scheme of
for that where you remain in the same
topic
maybe with questions that are simpler
and finally you go to a next level when
you get it right and all the history all
the paths that the student actually
follow can be stored and can be used as
data for the teacher right there are
many schemes this is only a first
approach now in order to do that we use
a front page one once again the same
idea we were Scheid of using ask
function which could be the best tool
for this because of the experimental
status so we actually did learn how to
use it with form with front page one of
the things that we had to solve is how
to store the information of different
students that might be using the app at
the same time and the information is not
overlapping or have a conflict and
actually the solution turned to be very
simple that was object we captured the
ID of the student we asked him or her to
input the ID yes you an ID and then the
name of the variables
as included the ID now that did solve
the problem but now I don't want you to
see my work from cloud account because I
have a lot a lot a lot of files with the
names and and of all the students and
all the tribes and all of that so there
is actually a better approach which is
not implemented here which actually is
use your URL field right the thing is
that when you build and you are ill
sorry the different parts of the path
are actually folders in the Wolfram
cloud so you do that and you have that
your your ID has for example the student
ID there's going to be a folder in your
one cloud and then you can have it
organized so here in this code and I am
including the code because maybe you
will one later to see later to see this
notebook from the presentation here when
we have the code you can see that the
name here is just a string join for the
name of a variable that is going to be
safe in the cloud now instead instead of
that string yo enjoin we have that your
URL build in order to have this
structure of folders to make it a
cleaner okay and they work on cloud
alright and okay well you also have here
well this is too small but I also have
here other thing that we were finding
when we were working with this I always
walk to the Mathematica Stock Exchange
or to the community to see the kind of
questions I have and I was kind of well
disappointed to see that there are not
so many questions answered about the use
of the warfarin cloud yeah do you have
some question there and it will be some
months before someone answers and well I
was kind of disappointed here so I we
were trying actually to make post over
there in the community and in the stock
exchange of all of these things and I
also have the link there trying to well
increase the use of these powerful tools
or the beautiful tools right
well one more time our identity learning
app works in computer laptop phone yeah
and just to give you a so you can see
the as I told you you you the student
will enter here the ID all right okay
and then we are going to start with the
questions these are just well the first
topic in this case is about intervals
and if he doesn't have the correct
answer then we will remain in the topic
of intervals right we will not go to the
next topic
right and then another question and then
another question etc and all the
unloaded part can be safe so the next
time we know how many times did he fail
did she fail right or if he/she gets the
answer right then we go to the next
topic right which in this case well it
was graph of functions and I we have
also message that well done your answer
was right cetera right and so it's
trying to have this kind of interaction
with it with the user right and saving
the information okay so okay so that was
fast
so we used the word front language
commands from function and front page in
order to implement cloud apps from a
while learning the ones for mechanical
design engineering have already been
used with success we use the we avoid
the double use of more advanced as
function family of commands because they
are mark experimental and there was an
advantage of that because we kind of
took the front function and the front
page commands to the to the edge or the
limit of what can be done with with them
right so I think we have a very good
grasp now of what can be done with those
commands we're up for learning in
mechanical and game design had a
positive effect which with the students
being able to find several successful
designs when traditionally they struggle
to find only one right I was also
possible to implement an adaptive
learning framework using the
kind of from page command that during
this process we were surprised to find
very few examples at the work on
community Mathematica Stack Exchange we
did contribute with our own findings and
now learning that we will have these
repositories for notebooks and other
repositories I am intending to create
more kind of tutorials to use these
commands so they get more more used
because they are beautiful I mean you
make some beautiful apps with that ok so
one of the future work besides 3d
printing will mean we are interesting
out that we are starting to generate
data to capture data from our students
well take advantage learn and take
advantage of the capacities of the
warfront language for data science and
for machine learning in order to use
that with the rate of our students would
be one of the directions of the future
work ok thank you very much
[Applause]